Edward, I'm going to
take care of you.
♪♪
What's it like beingfamous?
I'm not famous.
Yeah, okay.
This is grief counseling.
Anyone's invited to speak.
People meet me and they think,
she's the woman whose nephew
survived the plane crash.
But they forget I'm also...
the woman who
lost my big sister.
♪♪
What are you doing?
Drinking champagne by myself
out of a juice glass.
♪♪
I lost my husband,
I lost my best friend.
But he had another life.
So I don't know how to
piece it all together.
♪♪
After I got to 200,
I lost count.
♪♪
Why is everyone
writing to him?
Cause he survived.
♪♪
I know you want to run away.
I want to run away too,
but life has to go on.
♪♪
I don't know who I am.
Join the club.
♪♪
I'm sure you've heard
great things.
Oh no, no secrets
in grief group.
♪♪
My grandmother paved the way
and there is no one
more committed
to carrying on her
legacy than I am.
♪♪
What happened
isn't fair, Edward.
But I'm going to do my
best to take care of you.
And that is the truth,
that will never go away.
♪♪